We went to Mexico to look at the
sacred Cenotes in the Yucatan.
They used to be spiritual
places for the Mayans
today we come and we seek peace
and relaxation and meditation.
This is a Russian Orthodox
community on Epiphany day.
Now, you're probably gonna say
this is Russia, Ukraine, right?
No, it's Maine!
( audience laughter )
We went to India for the
Ganga Dussehra ceremony.
One-point-three million people
making offerings in
the sacred Ganges.
( sound of the river flowing )
It's a staggering event.
Again, where they light candles,
say prayers, beautiful.
If you ever get the chance
to go to Haridwar, do go.
And then wait just for dusk, and
it becomes the most beautiful,
poetic scene of humanity
in deep spiritual prayer
with the candles
moving down the river.
We went to look at the
commercialization
of the spirituality of
the Ganges, to Mumbai
to Bombay where a
giant water park
with the symbol of
the Ganga is there
and you can slide
down the Ganga.
We went to Turkey to look
at sacred water in Islam.
Ablutions before going
into the mosque to pray.
The Greek Orthodox
Church in Istanbul.
We know about baptisms
but let's do it in a
little more poetic way.
We don't have to see
all the nudity.
Went to Bali, to look at the
spirituality in Hinduism
where they pray where the water
is considered extremely sacred.
Japan, at a meditation center,
where people pray under dripping
and meditate under dripping
droplets of water.
The taoist outside of Kyoto
line up under candlelight
and pray for blessings under
cascading cold waterfalls.
And if you're gonna work
in an onsen, in Japan
and everybody is naked, you
kinda feel kinda funny
you're wearing your clothes and
everybody else is naked.
So, it's probably the only
assignment I've ever done
where I worked naked
for three days.
( audience laughter )
I just worked naked.
South of France
in a cave that is believed
that the Virgin Mary appeared.
Every day
thousands come to touch
the water seeping from the wall.
So desperate are some in pain,
they come in their hospital beds
praying for relief,
to touch that sacred water.